so uh yesterday despite the fact
that the mayor of kenosha wisconsin said
don't come here
the governor of wisconsin said don't
come here
donald trump forced his way to wisconsin
and had a round table event now later
i'm going to tell you about some of
these so
i it almost makes sense to call them
crisis actors that trump brought in for
this event
but before i get to that i want to
actually play some clips for you
of this completely toxic and pathetic
roundtable that donald trump did
which he started by saying everybody
maybe should look at taking their masks
off take a look at this it's a great
honor if you feel more comfortable
you'll say a couple of words you might
want to take the mask
off otherwise you can leave them on
either way you want look how fast you
took that
so again the language of
pandemic we beat that that's over we got
past the pandemic
already taking masks off is something
people
may want to do here we saw it with 1500
people
at his convention speech no coveted
tests no masks no social distancing
we're continuing to see this attitude of
the pandemic is in the past it's not
really a thing
anymore trump then again using this
analogy
about when police sometimes choke and
you would imagine that after everything
that's happened including george floyd
floyd and including the debate over
choke holds
maybe trump would have some other
metaphor to use here
but no and he also points out that he
feels very safe in wisconsin right now
jobs we can't be threatening them with
their pensions are going to be taken
away their jobs going to be taken away
everything's going to be taken away
they're going to be living a bad life
if if they utter an incorrect word
you can't do it we have to have our law
enforcement we cherish our law
enforcement we wouldn't be here without
our law enforcement
even me i'm here today i feel so safe
and you went through hell just a few
days ago but i feel so safe
i better be safe i better be safe but
we're all safe and we're safe because of
law enforcement
and we honor you and i will say this
we have to condemn the dangerous
anti-police rhetoric
it's getting more and more it's very
unfair
you have some bad apples we all know
that
and those will be taken care of through
the system
and nobody's going to be easy on them
either and you have people that joke
they're under tremendous i said it
yesterday i said it last night
they're under tremendous pressure so
trump kind of floated this idea in that
strange interview with laura ingram that
he did on sunday night i believe it was
or no wait actually it was monday night
where he said you know sometimes police
choke sort of like when you miss a three
put
a three foot putt in golf which was not
the most fine-tuned and delicate analogy
that maybe he could have done
and particularly in light of george
floyd and everything else
choking is probably not the word i would
be using
attorney general william barr one of the
most extreme
sycophants that we've ever seen hold the
position of attorney general
traveled to kenosha with donald trump
and
insists that the violence that happened
after the jacob blake shooting was not a
legitimate response
to a police shooting take a look at this
that erupted
shortly after the shooting is simply not
a legitimate response
to a police shooting and the looting
and the arson were unacceptable and as
it progressed it became more and more
distant from the issue of racial justice
it was violence for violence sake
so again i don't think there's anything
wrong with
saying looting and arson are not
acceptable forms of protest there are
people who think that they are
i happen to disagree and i think that
they are counterproductive forms of
protest more importantly but
notice that william barr didn't condem
kyle rittenhouse who has been charged
with homicide
trump didn't condemn kyle rittenhouse
and in fact
increasingly the right is making him out
to be a hero so
it's not so much about bar is wrong by
criticizing arson
it's that just focusing on arson
by leftists is number one completely out
of sync with what is actually happening
on the ground and number two ignoring
more than half of the story donald trump
was asked whether he thinks police
should wear body cameras this is super
interesting because what we're seeing
time and again is
trump is devoid of substance trump is
unable to discuss substance
and actual policy he just can't do it
and here trump is asked about body
cameras
he just hems and haws he literally gives
no answer because he can't
wear body cameras should every police
officer in the united states wear a body
camera
body cam
well that's very interesting let me ask
bill to answer that question this is
what it looks like
when your brain is mush trump is unable
unable to discuss actual policy
substance
even when it's a simple question just
bails out and asks
somebody else to help them with the
answer there was another instance of
this an attempt to get donald trump to
talk about substance the question was
very simple question do you believe
systemic racism is a problem in this
country
and donald trump just doesn't answer and
says oh we should be talking about
protests
we're focusing on violent actions but
there have been
countless non-violent protests here in
wisconsin and across the country
this summer people calling for an end to
systemic racism do you believe systemic
racism is a problem in this country
well you know you just keep getting back
to the opposite subject we should talk
about the kind of violence that we've
seen in
portland and here and other places it's
tremendous violence you always get to
the other side well what do you think
about this or that the fact is that
we've seen tremendous violence and we
will put it out very very quickly if
given the chance and that's what this is
all about
uh yeah i keep hearing about peaceful
protests i hear it about everything and
then i come into an area like this and i
see
the town is burned down i mean you look
at minneapolis
he just cannot answer it or he won't
answer it the question was not about
violence
in portland the question was simply do
you think systemic racism exists
this is maybe breaking news to some
people you can
simultaneously hold the beliefs uh
that arson is bad and
that there is reason for people to be
upset because of systemic racism in the
united states
you can hold that view you can now
whether trump
holds it or doesn't or is not willing to
say it that's a different question
there was a second attempt at basically
the same question
about systemic racism and systemic
change
trump still unable to answer it
that have happened you've acknowledged
some of them are peaceful they're
calling for structural
change mr blake was shot seven times in
the back
do you believe that there is a need for
structural change what is your message
well i think people
are calling for structural change and
then you could take the people of
kenosha
that aren't here and that you won't see
and that aren't protesting but they want
change also they want to see law and
order
that's the change they want they want
law and order just
cannot or will not acknowledge or
or even answer questions about systemic
racism
and aaron rupar on twitter asked a good
question
which is what's the point of these trips
to places like kenosha
he flies in meets with groups of
carefully selected sycophants
holds a round table where everybody
praises him and then flies back to dc
aaron arguing on twitter yesterday that
it's a complete waste of time and money
i i would say something else it's
actually counterproductive
when the local officials don't want you
there remember that the mayor of kenosha
said don't come here
the governor of wisconsin said don't
come here the owner
of a business that burned down refused
to participate
in the photo ops and they brought in
someone else to be
photographed with trump as if they were
the owners
of this business i'm going to talk about
that a little bit later but in the
meantime remember that you can
follow us on instagram at david pakman
show
and remember that this program is mostly
funded
mostly funded by individual members
who sign up at joinpakman.com if you're
enjoying the programming consider
supporting us with a membership it's
quick it's easy
and it takes under a minute to sign up
at joinpakman.com
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service at
privacy.com slash pacman privacy is a
service i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
if i don't have to companies don't have
to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra
security features but go ahead and sign
up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend just for signing up
when you go to privacy.com slash pacman